cette chose vous hantera chaque nuit qik
de soyaux aucun de nous ne devrait
affronter une telle force maléfique
sauvons les riches moins que vous vous
en sortirez au très bien merci
quelqu'un cherche à lâcher les morts sur
new york et nous sommes peut-être les
seuls à pouvoir sauver la ville pourquoi
c'est moi qui utilise le laser nucléaire
qu'on va tester à les bras les plus
longs fleuves femmes sont justes crise
je suis sûr qu'il s'est trompé de mots
des femmes frustré solitaire et triste à
mourir
or pour soi je viens pour le poste de
réceptionniste vous est prévu comme tu
transpires il met deux heures dehors qui
ont besoin d aide
ça roule à fond doit former un groupe et
fabriquer un truc pour combattre c'est
sa tête entoure
c'est exactement ce que ce que nous
faisons déjà ici je te signale monde à
lucerne
il va se passer un truc énorme
je pense que le mot que tu cherchais
apocalypse
j'ai bâti ma de villa derrière de
fantômes ne tient plus petits avaient
surtout le sien nous devons éviter
l'hystérie collective
j'étais à la ville kevin tu peux
répondre au téléphone dont il est dans
l'aquarium
c'est lui qui sur ton bureau à celui
d'un commence à peine au dessus des
experts en exploration métaphysique
ça roule elle souhaite fantôme parts à
une espèce de gros noms je suis fatigué
non non je vais sortir tranquillement
qu'est ce que me dit de ça je ne crois
pas que ce soit un gros je vais sortir
surtout l'énervé pas le 30 aux mains
vous êtes sérieux est bon
ça
mushtaq take off dont obsèques de guy